♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Okay, it's Tea ♪
♪ With Gary Vee ♪
♪ Sipping in for Vee ♪
♪ I know patience is the key ♪
♪ Putting in all of my shit for free ♪
♪ This is Tea with Gary Vee ♪
♪ Michael make a flip ♪
♪ Take a risk ♪
- Good morning.
Tea with Gary Vee, here we are.
It is April 16th.
April 16th and I am super excited.
Big day.
Sorry about yesterday, it
just been really intense here.
I don't know if you've saw,
but the All In Challenge is real.
Allinchallenge.com, please check it out.
I'm super excited about this
we have raised over $5,000,000
in the first 45 hours of this challenge.
The experiences are ridiculous.
Dustin get in here real quick.
Talk to me for a second.
(laughs)
Oh, Le'Veon Bell just texted me,
we're gonna get him in the challenge.
How sick are these things?
- It's pretty crazy.
I saw--
- Being a Chris Rock.
go ahead.
- I saw a couple ones
that are coming soon.
(laughs)
- Oh, the ones that are coming.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, you see Drake joined last night?
- Yeah, I think I saw it on your story.
- Yeah, so Drake's in the building.
It's just insane.
Matthew McConaughey.
- That one's great.
- The Justin Timberlake and
Bill Murray golf experience.
Did you see what Cuban's doing?
You can be on...
You will be an actual MBA player.
For $10.
- Yeah.
- You will be an actual MBA player.
A one-day contract, be on the team.
And then obviously the Gary Vee.
Did you see the Gary Vee,
fucking, ultimate experience?
- I paid for it (laughing)
- You're in it?
- I did the $25 dollar one.
I figured why--
- No you did not.
- I did.
- What do you want?
Garage sale with me?
- Yeah. (laughs)
- I'll take you.
All right, let's get into the show.
Let's get into the show.
If everybody's watching, please
go to allinchallenge.com,
find the Gary Vee ultimate experience,
buy a raffle ticket, 10 bucks,
and you can get a lot.
If you haven't seen the video, it's crazy.
Please support the All In Change minimally
by sharing the URL
and your favorite auction on social media
and I'd love to see some of you bid.
The ballers in here on auctions
and then for the people
that can't afford it,
especially during these times,
the raffle tickets are amazing.
You can literally be
in a Leonardo DiCaprio,
Robert De Niro, Scorsese movie for $10,
or be Ellen DeGeneres' co-host for $10.
Or Justin Bieber come to your house
and serenade you for $10.
Or make a TikTok with Charli
and Dixie D'Amelio for $10.
So, I'm excited about it.
Please pass it on.
It's just on the verge on exploding.
So, it's 18 and older, Rachel.
All right, let's get into it.
It is only a U.S. thing,
so find a U.S. friend, go in, and bid.
That's the laws and rules.
Bone, what's up?
Bone, what's good?
- What up, my guy?
- My guy, they got you on this?
That's what's up, man, how you feeling?
- I'm feeling good, man, how you doing?
- Super well.
Do these people know
that you're the only man
to defeat Floyd Mayweather?
Here he is, the man to beat him.
- Hey, thank you very much.
- What's your question bro?
- I'm so glad to actually
be on the show with you
and my question for you is,
I've been playing street
ball for over 20 years
and I was trying to
basically pick your brain on,
what would be my best objective
moving forward for my career
and using my social media
platforms to enhance that?
- Financially, how do
you get the most dollars
out of your street cred?
I think it comes in many different forms.
One, I think there's
an instructional video business for you.
Your handles are crazy.
Kid's want that so bad now,
more than even dunking.
I really do think that
there's a "free video,"
and then a premium video where
there's different videos,
and then they get you for one hour a week,
the whole group, 80 people, 5,000 people,
I think there's a real premium for that.
I think that's a $20 to
$40 subscription per month
that's $240 to $480 a year per person,
that shit adds up and it scales you
because if you're on livestream
like this for an hour,
for the 5,000 people that paid for it,
for the extra Q&A sessions on handles,
and culture, that's there.
I think you keep building
your social profile.
I think there's brand deals for you,
whether it's Champion,
whether it's Adidas,
whether it's Nike.
I really think that's
there for you as well
because in the culture you
matter to us that know,
and it's always about
that next step, right?
It's kind of like Hip-Hop, right?
There's the artist that the culture knows,
and then they cross
over and everybody knows
- Yeah
- And you watch all that.
So, I view you as a
cultural figure that way.
Video game culture, I think
there's so much going on.
Big shout out to Ronnie 2K
and that whole world, I
think there's a lot there
potentially, you being
a character in that.
One-ups, things like that nature.
So, those are the things
that really stand out.
But I think the biggest
place to make your money
is instructional classes,
building a video platform
that allows you to monetize
video content that's stagnant,
and then experiences live like this.
- Got you.
- My man.
Hope you staying healthy,
we'll see you soon.
- Hey, good to see you man, (mumbles).
- Good to see you, bro.
All right, everybody, little start.
Nice little tactical,
went out the gate with the Bone Collector.
Check him out for sure,
tactical execution.
What's good Travis Rogers?
What's good Vicky?
Lizarda Disney and the travel guy.
Now it's time, (mumbles), do do do do.
- Good morning, good morning, how are you?
- I'm well, good morning, how are you?
- I'm good, I'm good, Gary.
My name is Elie.
I'm a 19-year-old magician
from Cleveland, Ohio.
- That's awesome.
- And I actually had the
opportunity in October 2019
to come to VaynerMedia
and hang out with the team
which was awesome, dude, it was great.
Those guys know what they're doing.
- Thank you.
- And I learned more
than I could ever imagine
when it comes to social media and stuff,
and I got to show Justin and Sid and Kate
some awesome magic,
but I was kind of bummed
because you weren't here.
- I wasn't there?
I'm sorry.
- So, before I get into my question,
I do have a deck of card.
I would love if you just named
a card right now, any card.
Don't make it obvious like
the ace of spades, Gary.
- Five of Hearts.
- Five of Hearts, are you sure
you want the five of hearts?
- I'm sure.
- Okay, cool man.
So, I'm gonna show you,
I'm gonna keep the deck
in the screen here,
I'm gonna open it up,
I'm gonna take the cards out of the deck,
and you said five of hearts.
- That's right.
- I'm gonna go through, go through,
There should be one upside
down card right there.
- What?
- If I flip it, the five--
- This is the shit, I fuck with this shit.
(laughing)
- You know?
I fuck with magic man.
- The five of hearts, man.
(laughing)
- That's super good, man.
I still...
I love that man.
- Thank you.
- That's super fucking impressive.
- I just had to get that
out of the way (laughs).
- Dude, you just blew everybody's mind.
I promise you.
(laughing)
Ten thousand people just
said, "What the fuck?"
(laughing)
- I promise you, amazing.
- Dude, that's awesome.
Yeah, man, I was super bummed out,
I was like, "Ah, man,
I got to show Gary some
magic sometime though."
- Big shout out to all
the hardcore Gary Vee fans
that know exactly why
it's the five of hearts.
The this and the this.
Bit shout out.
- That's cool, logo. (laughs)
- I see somebody picking it up.
What's good bud?
- I love it, man.
So, my question for you today is,
with those whole crazy pandemic
and everything going on,
as an influencer, someone
whose built a following
because of magic and everything,
I want to ask what your advice would be
to me and all the
influencers around the world,
how can we spread a positive
and a motivational message to our--
- Do exactly what I'm doing right now.
- Stream, just...?
- Yeah.
- Give value.
- Cool, man.
I actually put out a
music video as a joke.
A Lonely Island type
music video the other day.
It got over 1,000 views
in the first two days,
and that was amazing to me.
- The content thing is inherently,
subconsciously selfish.
The stream thing has
more selflessness, right?
And it's awesome, I make
content all day long.
- Right.
- I'm not trying to, that's
amazing that you did that.
But what you just did is incredible,
you should be doing that
for fucking an hour a day
and then the next hour, teaching people
how to do magic tricks.
- Oh, okay, yeah.
- Same thing I gave Bone Collector.
I think this is an incredible platform
for magicians to scale,
where they put out all
sorts of fun content
which is the tricks,
they put out some things
where they teach people,
and then again, 50 bucks a month,
it's a big business in my opinion.
- Yeah.
- You're really teaching
people on the other side
how to actually do what the fuck...
The slight of hand, whatever
you just did there for that.
I don't even know what the fuck you did.
(laughing)
But I know the skill is
there and teaching people,
I think there's something
cool there, so two things.
One, just flat-out doing
it for free to bring value,
because it will bring a lot of value.
- Absolutely.
- Because if you want
to actually bring value,
those people are gonna
be able to potentially,
there's a lot of social media magic
personality brands that are emerging.
It's a real thing.
- Oh, yeah.
- And what's you're Instagram handle?
A lot of people are asking.
Oh there it is, I see it, I see it.
- My Instagram handle
is @eliemagic
- Yep, yep.
And so, listen, the one thing that I do
that's very different then everybody else,
is I actually give away
my best advice for free.
- That's (Gary speaks over Elie).
- So, the ultimate thing you can do
is give away your best advice for free.
- Absolutely, man.
- Not everybody can afford that,
not everybody has that altruism in them,
not everybody's looking for the legacy.
Everybody's wired different.
So, the next best thing you can do
is give away half of it for free
and then have a paywall
for the other half.
- Yep.
- But the best thing anyone can do
is spend tons of time
which is not scalable,
like right now I have
this All In Challenge,
I don't know if you saw it but it's--
- I did dude, it's crazy man.
So awesome.
- Dude, I expect you to buy
a couple raffle tickets.
- Absolutely.
- Just something.
- Yeah, absolutely man.
- Maybe playing golf with...
But, I...
I still am finding time to do this,
and I've got the company and
all sorts of headaches there.
I've got this charity thing
that I'm putting all
this fucking energy into.
I slept like three hours last
night, four hours last night.
It's just fucking giving.
- Yeah.
- You know what I mean bro?
- We got to do that, yeah.
- Everyone's like, "Gary, how
do I give the most value?"
I'm like, "Fucking give."
- Yeah.
- And a lot of people want to half give
with something in return.
- A lot of people are
expecting that return, man.
When that shouldn't be the goal.
- And guess what?
Actually giving creates
the greatest return.
- Yes (laughs).
- It's just not transactional.
It's forever.
- Absolutely, man.
- There's something I'm gonna do this week
that'll pay dividens in some shape or form
31 years from now.
- Wow.
- I won't be able to make
the transactional connection
but something good might
happen for my daughter.
- Yeah.
- Based on the impact I
made on somebody right now.
- Yeah, and that's the whole point, man.
That's great.
- Too much half-giving.
AKA manipulation.
- Right. (laughs)
- AKA trying to get people
to do what you actually want
by giving something bullshit up front.
- 100% man, 100%
- So.
Awesome
- Hey, if you ever come
to Cleveland, dude.
Come check out the
(mumbles), man (laughs).
- Listen, I'm definitely gonna come to--
I went to Cleveland a couple years ago
for a devastating Jets game
(laughing)
when the Browns finally
one their first game
in like two years.
But I love Cleveland, I'm a big fan.
So, I'll see you there.
- Thank you man, take care.
- Take care.
- Peace out.
Let's keep this going.
Yummy, what's good?
Josh, what's good?
- What's good, Gary?
How's it going?
Good to see you again.
- Doing well.
Good to see you.
- So, just a little, quick back story,
I had a ton of shoulder pain
while I was playing baseball growing up
and eventually tried a
bunch of different things
and eventually found someone that helped,
similar to massage, kind of.
So, I eventually got
into that, trained on--
- Soft tissue?
- Yeah, soft tissue work.
So, I eventually--
- Is that what you're talking about?
- Yeah, soft tissue.
- Josh, I'm fucking obsessed.
Do you know that?
- Gary, I'm in Minnesota.
So, you come here for Rocker, I got you.
- Me and Mike Vacanti,
my current trainer is from Minnesota.
Bro, I'm obsessed.
- I've been messaging him too
but I couldn't get ahold of him.
- Send me an email to Gary
at VaynerMedia right now
and be like, "Soft Tissue
Guy on Team Gary Vee."
- All right.
- And we'll get it done.
Bro, I'm obsessed.
- Let me know.
I travel too so I could come
to the hotel or whatever.
- I've done 20 to 30 minutes...
I do 20 minutes of soft tissue work a day.
It's changed my life.
- That's where I'm trying to get to
but I don't have the money for that yet.
(laughing)
- Bro, but, I'm doing it...
Yeah, I understand.
- Yeah.
- And Mike's not doing it for me.
I'm doing it with a soft ball.
My fucking trap.
- Oh, working on yourself.
Working you yourself, yeah.
- Yeah, working on myself.
- Okay.
- Bro, but even doing it yourself,
and obviously,
- Oh yeah.
- I'm sure what you do is...
It's fucking amazing.
- Yep.
Even just that one little bit.
If you're consistent with it.
- Someone just put up there
and said foam rolling.
It's not foam rolling.
- No.
- It's way deeper than that.
- I mean, that will help
but it's not the same.
- Yeah, foam rolling's nice.
- Yeah.
- But this is fucking like...
Right now I'm kind of okay,
but usually I have heavy bruises.
- Yeah.
- On my body.
Because I'm in it, in between my ribs.
- There you go.
- It fucking changed my life.
My QL.
- Oh yeah.
- On my left was completely broken.
Used to go out.
- Yeah.
- Broken, Josh.
- Which then makes you
have horrible back pain
and you can't move.
- Correct, I used to be out.
- Yeah.
- Literally couldn't move for two days.
- And then my neck was all fucked up
and, dude, I'm...
And now I do it on my fucking arm,
my inner like....
I have bruises sometimes
all over the place.
I'm into my bicep now
and it fucking hurts.
- I haven't seen you this
excited about something
since talking about wine.
- Dude, it's super true.
(laughing)
Honestly, I think you're
in a very intriguing...
Jesus, crap, a very interesting field.
- No, you're good.
- Thank you.
- Yeah (laughs).
- That is profession.
- Yeah.
- Jesus fucking Christ.
I think it's about to explode,
kind of like meditation.
- Yep, yep.
- Kind of like working out itself,
kind of like eating healthy.
I'm obsessed.
- I'm glad to hear that.
So, I eventually got into this because
I want help get other people
to the point where I was it
because I was in a ton of pain,
couldn't really play baseball very well.
I got to the point where I
could come back and play,
so I want to be able to
help people to do that,
that, "Hey, I can't pick up my grandkids
because my back hurts so bad,"
or whatever it is.
- Oh, it's real dude.
- And event--
- Great, keep going.
- Yeah, eventually I want to
get to professional athletes
because I want to optimize
their performance to,
- I got it.
- jump an inch higher,
run a (mumbles)
- Can I give you a great piece of advice?
- Hit me.
- Put out multiple
videos a day, two a day,
on Instagram about soft tissue work,
whatever you got, whatever you got.
So those two...
Go ahead
- So, last week,
I just started a self-care video series.
Every morning I'm putting out
a, "do this with your neck,
do this with your shoulder."
- Next, get a library of
a hundred videos, right?
- Yep.
- Then, everybody who
wants to figure this out,
go follow Josh.
Josh, how many followers
you got on Instagram?
Let's do this.
- 800 some.
- This is about to fucking
help so many people.
Josh is about to be super pumped.
(laughing)
But way more importantly,
people who go to chiropractors,
people that go to fucking massages,
- Yeah.
- Are about to completely...
I'm following you back,
you just got me as a follower, Brother.
Which will help you with...
- That's huge.
- All right, you're at 850 right now.
You were 847 a second ago.
- Oh, geeze.
Watch this, here we go, Josh.
You ready for...
Get ready.
- I'm not prepared for this.
- By the way, the other day
we did it for the other person
because it was nice.
Today, it's gonna help a ton of you.
I used to do massages,
I went to chiropractors.
There's nothing even remotely close.
It changed my life.
- I'm happy to hear you say that
because I tell it to people all the time,
and they don't (mumbles)
- Josh, look at this, 945.
- Oh, boy.
I'm not ready for all this.
- You are ready.
Listen to me, you are ready.
(laughing)
Let me tell you what's important.
- Yeah.
- You have to DM a hundred
at, where do you live?
- Minneapolis, Minnesota.
- Oh, Minnesota.
You have to DM a hundred Twins,
Timberwolves, and Vikings.
You have to DM them all
and say, "I will do this free.
This will help you."
- I do, they don't respond.
- Brother, you don't get it.
You don't get it.
- I'll keep going.
- Correct, one day one person responds.
- Yep.
- All changes.
- And I've made some pretty
good contacts here too.
- You've not DM'd every single Viking,
every single--
- No, not every single one.
- Thank you, thank you.
- Yeah.
- But that's the shit I talk about.
- I know (laughs)
- I talk about going fucking all in.
And people are like, "Yeah, I'm all in."
- Yeah.
- Josh, this is gonna help everybody out.
This is not embarrassing.
- Oh, I know.
- This is important to me.
How many Vikings, tell the truth,
I know it's gonna be
an embarrassing number,
so don't worry.
How many Vikings, Twins, and Timberwolves
have you actually DM'd, tell.
- Combined?
- Yes. Tell the truth.
- 15 to 20.
- Good, all of them.
50+ on the NFL team.
50 on the basketball team.
- I'm working on getting
to Esports too and...
- The Rockers?
The Rockers?
I can help with that.
- All right.
- I'm a team owner now, this is weird.
- Yeah, so I'm at--
- Okay you know what else is weird?
You know what else is weird?
- The thing...
Oh, boy.
I, yeah, wow.
That's something.
I was not expecting that.
- Here's the best part
for me on this one, Josh.
You're pumped right now, I can see it.
And it's a big moment that's
gonna change your career.
- Yeah.
- I'm pumped for people that
are following you right now
that have any kind of pain.
Guys, everybody's
watching, check this out.
The brain doesn't want you fixing
the shit that hurts the most.
It's the crazy game that
I've learned a lot about.
It's a really--
- Eventually the muscles just get
de-connected from the brain.
The stimulation back and forth.
And so, getting in there
and working on them.
Re-connecting them to the brain.
- Josh, I lived this the last four years.
Changed my life.
What's the inner thigh,
what's that called again?
This one right here?
- You're VMO.
- This right here?
- Yeah, your VMO.
- Yeah, this fucking thing, fucking my QL.
On my right side it was over here.
- Yeah.
- And on my left I was like, "eh."
(laughing)
There's this crazy
picture that Jordan has.
He fucking worked it,
it's like all fucking...
It's amazing, I can't even
believe what happened.
It fucking is amazing, bro.
I'm obsessed with soft tissue.
- Okay, the first question
that I was trying to think is,
- Oh right, we had a question right?
- Yeah. (laughs)
How do I market a therapy
that people don't know about?
But I feel like I watch
enough of your content
that I answered that on my own,
and it's content that teaches...
Oh, boy.
Content that teaches people so
putting out videos and stuff.
- Yeah, don't worry.
Don't read what you fucking
wrote, it didn't matter.
Listen to me.
- Okay, the one I do have
a question though is,
- Go ahead, go ahead.
- A week ago or two you
were talking with someone
doing a shirt business or something
and you were saying how
brick and mortar stores
are going away.
- No, nope.
Brick and mortar stores
are gonna be challenged.
- Challenged.
- Lease prices have to come down.
I actually predict in 2025, 2030, 2035,
that brick and mortar stores
is gonna be a good play
because lease prices are
gonna come down so much
because so many people are
going direct to consumer,
the internet.
Now, with COVID, so many people.
In the comments, people...
Actually watch this.
In the comments, everybody.
Leave the thing that you bought
that you never bought
on the internet before.
You used to buy it in the store
that you're blown away
with and you're enjoying.
Soap, bubblegum, whatever.
- I want to know.
- Go ahead.
- What do I do if something
like this happens again?
Because I'm fortunate right now
to be at my parent's house,
I don't really have any bills to pay
and so this is, not convenient.
It's convenient but if this happens again,
I'm getting married in September
and I'll have bills to pay,
because I can't work.
I can't go--
- Yes, you can.
- I can't.
That's why I'm trying--
- You can work.
- How can I work right now?
- Start a subscription business
that lets you virtually
train people on soft tissue.
That's how Mike Vacanti and Jordan do it.
- Okay.
How do I...
- How do you do that?
- Yeah.
- So, the service, this
thing called Google.
- Wow.
- It goes, "How do I start a virtual..."
- All right.
- But I'm serious.
- It's all online, yeah, yeah.
- Honestly, you'll appreciate this.
This morning I worked soft tissue.
- Yeah.
- For 35 minutes.
- Because it was an ab day,
I didn't need the whole hour, right?
And Mike was on video like this,
and my laptop was like this.
- Yep.
- And we did the work.
- All right.
- Now, so you coming in and
doing that fucking stick.
- Yep.
- And scrape the fuck,
and I got the bruises.
That's different,
but that can be a plus up
to what you do digitally.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And by the way, you
can't live in fear brother.
- No.
- It's a pandemic that...
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's the first pandemic in a century.
- Yeah.
- But you've got to be
prepared for anything.
- That's what I'm trying to be,
so that next time this happens I don't...
- Listen, I--
- And that helps me scale it too
so that I can reach more people
because as of right now
I'm in a 30 mile radius in Minneapolis.
- That's right, bro.
Your scale in this regardless,
if there was no fucking
Corona, this would be advice.
I said, "What?
- Yeah.
- You're gonna get 42 clients?"
And what?
Then you're business is capped.
What then you're gonna hire somebody else
and then she leaves because
she's got her own practice,
you're gonna be sad and lose the clients.
Fucking, scale to virtual, bro.
- Yeah.
That's what I needed, yeah.
- Bro, good news.
- When it comes to marketing strategy.
- Yes.
- I know the body, I
do not know marketing,
and I don't have money to
pay anybody to do that.
- So, you're gonna learn.
You're gonna learn.
- But, I also don't feel like I have...
You always talk about testing ads.
I don't necessarily really
know what I'm doing,
and so, I feel like testing
a crap ton of ads...
- Look, you're gonna appreciate this.
First of all, testing ads can cost $10.
- I know, I've been spending five bucks
on some ads on Facebook.
- Anything happen yet?
- I don't usually get anything out of it.
I don't feel like...
- Well five bucks is fucking,
I mean, you can (mumbles) fucking tough.
- Yeah, I mean, I...
And I get it, listen, I'm with you.
Stay with me.
- In my recent one.
- Please.
- When I just posted in three days,
I've had 16 clicks on
whatever to go to my website.
- Understood, understood.
Until you get a client,
- Yeah.
- it doesn't matter how many leads, right?
- I mean, look, this is not the time.
No body wants you
- No.
- to fucking come to their
house and touch them.
So, fucking, you have
to keep that in mind.
- Right now I'm doing free
virtual consultations.
- And, getting anybody?
- No, not yet.
I'm going live tonight.
- Good news, ready?
- Yeah.
- Not, 50, bro, you got fucking.
Literally, you walked in here
with 800 fucking followers.
- All right.
- Look at this, 1,999, I promise you...
Everybody who just followed
who actually has pain,
who actually, not everybody.
Don't take advantage of the dude.
If you actually had pain the way I did,
and you've actually gone to chiropractors,
and you've actually gone to masseuses,
please DM him right now
that you followed him
and said you in for the live
or you're in for the consultation.
Josh, we just started your
business right now, bro.
We just changed your fucking life.
- I appreciate that.
- I appreciate you.
- Thank you, sir.
- You're welcome, bro.
Keep pushing.
- Als--
- Sorry.
- No, I'll shoot you that email.
- Please.
- Thank you.
- I'm looking forward.
I will 100% do it.
- Yeah.
Appreciate.
- When I come to the next Rocker thing,
or if I got to Minnesota on some business.
- Awesome, let's do it.
- I'm gonna let you
take some fucking sticks
and scrape the fuck.
- You and the team too,
whoever's struggling.
- I appreciate it man.,
it bro, we'll do it.
We'll do it.
Thank you, bro.
- Yep, thank you.
- Soft tissue work,
I'm telling everybody,
it's a good transition.
Soft tissue work makes
me think of Wine Text.
Boom!
Today Wine Text has a
ridiculous Zinfandel.
I haven't written it up yet
so I have to do it right after the...
Dustin!
Boom!
- Sorry, sorry, there's
a little bit of a crisis.
- Boom!
(laughing)
Crisis on content on the All In Challenge?
- No, I'd rather not say publicly,
because...
- Is everything okay?
- Yeah, it's just backend stuff.
- Got it.
- I'll tell you later.
- Something's not live?
- No, no, no, no.
I'll tell you later.
- Text me right now.
- Okay. (laughs)
- Text me with it, we'll see.
Wine Text.
Seriously, though, if you are buying wine,
and a ton of you are,
I see the macro data,
there's a good amount...
Listen, I'm gonna go guilt right now,
there's a good amount of you
that buy wine at the
supermarket and you overpay,
buy wine at Total Wine
or BevMo! or Binny's
or Publix or the local liquor store.
It really hurts my feelings
that you haven't signed up for Wine Text
and supported my dad
If you just signed up for Wine Text,
if I finally broke you with this guilt,
and by the way, it's
crazy that it's guilt,
because it's the best
wine service in the world.
Literally, the best deals,
and it just hurts my feelings
that a lot of you have
not signed up for it
and you get tons of value,
you're like, "Yeah, Gary's the best,"
and you literally can't even
sign up for my dad's service
that I've been really asking for.
Got it.
That's easy, Dustin, you
got that under control.
Who signed up for Wine Text right now?
I know that Utah, there's
some states that you can't
so I appreciate the
people that are saying,
but I want to see it right now.
This is a U.S. only thing.
But, honestly on some real shit,
let me just go real shit,
you're making a ridiculous
mistake if you drink wine,
and you're not signed up for Wine Text
and you know who I am,
and you know what Wine Text is.
It takes three minutes to sign up,
you get a deal a day,
the deals are stupid.
Yesterday was a $42 Chianti for $18,
like that kind of stuff.
Today is a $28 Zin for
like 14 bucks, 17 bucks.
You're literally overpaying at stores,
you're literally massively
underpaying here,
you literally reply with "six, 12,"
how many bottles you want,
it gets shipped, its the easiest.
Somebody literally Tweeted,
"Amazon's complicated
compared to Wine Text."
Let me see.
Let me see who's just signed up.
Boxy Nerd says, "I'll check it out."
I don't want checking it out.
"I got my first two bottles
yesterday, it was excellent."
Let's go, Virgil.
Let's go.
I'm staying on this for a second
until I see a good amount.
Everyone, Yuri, everyone should sign up.
Oh, there's tons of old world wine maps.
We got some real Burgundy coming.
Signed up, Yuri, let's go.
I know some people,
listen, you don't drink,
you can't afford it right now, totally...
Yes, Maryland, I can,
Hassam, get in there,
no Canada sorry, no Australia.
If you're in Canada, Australia,
you need to go empathywines.com
and take care of that because
that's what it's about.
That's nice, a lot of people
are gonna share it on Facebook.
That's cool.
Actually, that's a good call out,
a lot of people aren't drinking...
Janet Turner, thank you
so much for signing up,
but if you don't drink,
it would mean a lot,
Patrick Wood, thank you so much, bro.
By the way, do not sign up...
It cost money to send a text,
so do not sign up if you don't drink wine.
Because it cost us money
and if you're not gonna
buy anything, that's bad,
my dad will be mad.
But honestly, if you drink wine,
no Michigan, Lanelle, thank you though.
"I just signed up, I don't drink,
but great for gifts."
That's fair enough, Jess,
but if you don't buy gifts often, Jess,
you can un-sign up.
'Cause it cost money.
But please, everybody share
it in your Facebook group,
and in your Facebook
account with the link.
That would mean a lot to me.
There's so many people that drink wine
that are part of these dumb wine clubs
that they bought ads from on Facebook,
or just buy at their local store
and pay 20% to 40% more.
Ours is 50% to 70% less.
It's like...
Love it.
Love it, "signed up," there's a signed up.
Sorry, I'm in the mood right now for this.
"I'll get all my friends to sign up."
Shelly Marie, thank you.
Please hit me up on Twitter with the links
where you posted the stuff.
That means a lot to me.
There are great, great
deals, I'm telling you.
Thanks, Box Wines, really good.
Let's see.
"Weed Text, Liquor Text, Beer Text,"
I see you, Fams.
Tameka, thank you so much of signing up.
Just signed up, appreciate it.
All right, let's do it.
Thank you, Tameka.
- Hey Gary.
- How are you?
- I'm fantastic, it's been a long time,
been trying to get on here.
I'm glad I'm actually on.
- I'm glad you're on.
What's good?
- I'm an aspiring inventor,
I'm working on a lot of things right now,
and I noticed that everyone's
in on the All In Challenge.
- Yes, yes.
- By the way, I got 25
votes for you already.
Trying to win here.
- I hope you win it, bro.
I hope you win.
Leore, thank you for signing up, go ahead.
- Everyone's trying to work
on how to feed the hungry
and stuff like that
for the Corona Virus,
and actually, I don't mind if
someone else takes this idea,
but I think it'd help a lot of people out,
they should do vertical gardens
for local cities, using aeroponics.
I think that'll help out.
In the next two months it
can have everybody have
at least some type of food on their plate.
And it's not that expensive.
I think that's a good thing to look into
for everybody who's
actually trying to help out.
- I love that, can you send me an email
with four of five links so I
can get a little more educated?
I know a lot about hydroponics,
Scott's Miracle Grow, and those guys
we do some business with.
They're doing a bunch
of different initiatives
to try to help feed,
the obviously come from a different place,
different angles.
Would love to get a little more educated
one what you're talking about.
- Yeah, definitely, definitely.
- Thanks, Jesse.
- Aeroponics is a next
step up from hydroponics.
- Yep, cool.
- You'll love it when you (mumbles).
I'll send you an e--
- I got a good base on hydroponic,
but I'd love to learn.
- Yes sir, definitely.
- Thank you, brother.
- I love to talk about anything.
- Any question?
- Yes, my question is,
I'm starting a new business right now.
Now I think is the perfect time for this
because I have enough time
to grow while everyone's away.
So, I look at this as a good opportunity.
But my business has never been done,
the type of business I
have has never been done.
If you don't have anything
to look forward to
or look for as far as good example,
what do you base your example off of?
You know how you say if one
person would have done it,
then you can look at it and check it out?
- No, no, that's more of your dwelling,
like I can from an alcoholic father,
I'll never make myself of anything.
And I'm like, but the other people
that have alcoholic parents,
innovators have nothing to look for.
- Yeah.
- There was no text deal a day site
when I came up with Wine Text.
(laughing)
I had to build it.
It was in my head.
- Awesome.
- Twitter was in Jack Dorsey's head, bro.
Because he loved the CB
radio when he was a kid.
- That's how he came up with Twitter?
I got to look into that more,
something interesting story behind there.
- It's a very interesting story.
- Yep.
Well, actually, you tell me,
I'm trying to get a bunch of people,
'cause right now I have a
plan to get my business out
in the next eight months.
I'm working on it now.
But, you said, "Go talk to famous people."
I feel, I haven't counted
how many people I talked to already,
but everyday I'll cash out
as much as Instagram will let me cash out.
- Well when you say,
"Speak to famous people,"
what are we talking about now?
Because one thing to get
influencers to give awareness,
what are you looking to do?
Get investors or get...
- Yeah, so what I'm trying to do
is to get investors or somebody
who believes in the idea
to the point that they're
willing to talk about it
a little bit.
Not the vertical garden thing,
that is just a reason
for the All In stuff.
My actual idea is a gym
that pays it's members to work out,
using a generator I created.
Right now, the 5-0 Energy guy,
I can't remember his name,
but he made something like that.
He gets 900 kilowatts
per hour for his bikes.
I get about 2,000 plus for the same thing.
- Interesting.
- So I'm working on getting my--
- Really quick, what's
your Instagram handle,
so people that are listening right now be,
"Oh, I got something for him."
- I don't even know my
Instagram handle, I'm so sorry.
- That's okay, that's okay.
- It's like Jason Santana 91 or something.
- Take one second, take something.
Are you on your phone right now?
- Yes, I am.
- Find your fucking Instagram handle.
I don't care if it goes dark,
we'll get you back in.
Find it right now.
- All right, let's see.
- While we're waiting for Jesse,
let's put up a link for Wine Text.
Winetext.com.
Bam!
Good job, Dustin.
Some of you have not signed up yet.
I'm telling you right now, if I found out
anybody who watches this
free show buys wine.
If you don't buy wine,
if you can't afford wine,
if you don't drink wine, we're good.
If I find out that you drink
even a bottle of wine a week
and you're night signed up
for this, we got a problem.
All right, get this out.
Jesse you got it?
- Yes, sir.
- Go ahead.
- Yes, it's Jesse, Jesse.Santana91,
and that's my Instagram handle.
- Why 91?
- That's the year I was born, '91.
- I love it.
Bro, your hair is on fire.
- Thanks, it stays up like this naturally.
I just woke up like this.
- I love it.
Jess, I think LinkedIn might be
an interesting place for you.
You're intellect might
be scaling a little...
That's different than a
coffee to consumer customer
or Wine Text.
Your playing a little
bit of a higher plane.
I think you might get more fruitfulness
on messaging on LinkedIn.
- I'm on LinkedIn.
- I would do homework.
- I have it.
- Being on LinkedIn and
fucking going in there
and writing a meaningful
message to 100 people a day,
is a very different game.
- It's true, that's true.
Might be--
- I need you to work LinkedIn.
People are like, "I got a gym!"
I'm like, "Do you work out in it?"
(laughing)
- Yeah.
- I know you've got LinkedIn,
I need to you to work LinkedIn.
- Yep, definitely.
I'm definitely going to start that now.
I'm going to message as people
today on LinkedIn as I can
before they kick me out.
- And make it custom, right?
When you hit up the
five energy drink, CFO,
and say you know this because of this,
or somebody else who understands,
somebody who's built big gyms,
the founder of Orange Theory
or Planet Fitness.
There's a lot of different
ways you can go, Jess.
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah.
- I'm definitely going to
start looking into this.
I appreciate the time.
- I got you, fam.
Talk to you soon.
- And I'll definitely email you
more about all those things.
- All right, man, take care.
- You too, bye.
- Bye.
He's got the little one
next to him, I love it.
Like this intimacy.
I like it.
It's good to see everybody.
Bachran, what's in the building?
Wine Text in Canada, can't do that.
But Empathy Wines is available in Canada.
Empathywines.com is a play.
First time on, Dany V.
What's good?
Kaiwan, "what's up?"
Trying to create new
things every day, trying.
What's good, Rudy?
What's good?
"Do my best to invest in
the All In Challenge."
Yeah, anybody for the All In Challenge,
really excited about it.
We're raising a ton of money.
Allinchallenge.com.
Please go check it out,
buy some of these raffle
tickets it's nuts,
be in a Kevin Heart movie
with a speaking line,
co-host with Ellen DeGeneres,
Daryl Strawberry's is in the building
with an incredible package.
Just a lota, lota amazing stuff.
Meek Mill's selling his
Phantom, bidding that off.
Tom Brady's first game in Tampa,
he's gonna fly you out,
you're gonna be go to the games,
he's got a dinner with you.
Now he's not a Patriot,
I definitely have a little less hate.
Let's keep this going.
Got someone for me, Dust?
- Hey, Gary, how are you? (laughs)
- I'm well, Adriana, how are you?
- I'm doing great,
thanks for having me on.
I've been listening to you for...
I've been watching and listening to you
for quite some time.
Quick backstory, so I'm 47 years old,
I have four kids, three
are on the autism spectrum,
I was never an athlete growing up,
I ate and drank my way through college,
gained 50 pounds, lost it in my 20s.
So, I've been a fitness professional
and a corrective exercise
specialist since,
which, by the way, I'm following Josh now
'cause he's soft tissue guy.
That's right up my alley.
- Are you a big believer in that?
While we're still on that subject.
- Yeah, very much so.
Very, very much so, I think that--
- Adriana, why do so few
people know about it?
- Well, I think it has to
do with body awareness.
I think, as you understand
the muscular skeletal system,
you start to understand how
the muscles, joints, and tendons work,
and I'm a big believer, in
trying to relieve the pain,
you don't want to chase the pain,
but you want to find the source.
When you understand the
different plains of motion,
how things are moving,
then you're better able to--
- That makes sense to me,
but why is it not know
in the consciousness of America as much?
- Probably 'cause it
hasn't been such a huge...
It hasn't been a big emphasis
until a lot of people have had
some societal-related pains.
So, I often say that my clients,
the ones who are the moves
and shakers in their careers,
are the ones who have had
the really poor posture.
- Yeah.
- And have had--
- I'm the worse, I'm the worse.
And Aaron L. just said,
"Soft tissue takes time and it hurts."
Such a good point.
- Indeed.
- You have to be patient
and be willing to take...
I mean, it fucking hurt.
I scream sometimes.
- Yeah, yeah.
- When you hit that spot
that you had no idea was the spot, I jump.
- Yeah, and I'll tell you,
it has to do with the Golgi tendon,
so when pressure's applied
to that muscle system,
the Golgi tendon tells that
muscle fiber to chill out,
so that pressure creates that
change in that muscle group,
and that's why massage therapy
has always been successful,
but just trying to release
that adhesion is huge.
- Yeah, okay, got to get going.
(Gary and Adriana
speaking over each other)
- Okay, I'm a big believer in it,
so being a fitness professional,
I've taught group fitness
classes, private clients,
now with all of this being a hard pivot,
I've had to get creative,
and how do I continue to service?
And how do I continue to reach the masses?
I definitely want to
target people 40 and up.
Me being 47, I feel we
still have a lot of time.
- You know what my favorite
part of this call is?
You're dropping 47 several times,
because you know the
comments are coming in that,
"Oh my God, she looks so great!"
(laughing)
I know what you're doing!
I know your game!
Keep going.
- Well, I feel like, don't
let age be your cage.
Look how much life
expectancy that we have left.
- Preaching, preaching.
- I've obviously shifted online
and so have a lot of
fitness professionals,
and I'm trying to stand out,
so in the last couple of weeks,
I've had some incredible groups
that I've been involved in,
thinkers, movers, and shakers
within the fitness industry,
and so I came up with the idea
of a small coaching,
nutrition coaching group.
I call it "Nourish Masters."
Anyway, long story short,
what it is is it's three months,
it's live streaming, nutrition coaching,
it's doing the demos for
menu prep, menu selections.
We're doing a little bit--
- Yeah, this is huge.
- Yeah.
- The fitness and health space virtually,
and the business space.
Virtual coaching, training
it's going to be...
It's huge already and
now everybody realize,
"Oh shit, I'm supposed to be doing this."
- Yes, exactly, and so I'm
trying to grow my group,
and actually we're doing
a hard launch on Saturday,
so my deadline is Friday
for everyone to register.
Or for those who feel like
this would work for them.
I'm trying to fit, my
immediate question is,
what are some strategic
things that I can do
between and now midnight my time Friday,
because I'm in Colorado that will--
- First of all,
the whole framework of
that strategy concerns me
because it's the reverse
of soft tissue work,
its fast and so your pants
are on fire right now.
- Okay.
- When your pants are on fire,
it leads to sell-y, dirty...
Like, you're just right
now, and I respect it
because I love the grind.
But right now, and you know this,
you can feel it in your body right now,
you're Helter Skelter, you're like,
"I need as many people in the funnel,
so that when I go in for
the ask and try to sale,
if I have a thousand people and I get 10%,
it'll be better than if I
have 40 people and have 10%"
My question is,
when you put a time
limit like this, Friday,
there may be financial reasons,
I have a lot of respect,
three children with autism, that's a lot.
- It is, it's a different...
I'll tell you, you talk about humility,
and my journey, it is what it is,
and I accept it,
I just have to roll up my
sleeves a little higher then
the next person.
- 100%
And to your point,
somebody may not have that situation,
but they have something else.
Everybody's home's got
some sort of challenges
and different things.
My biggest concern is, can I
get you to not do it Friday?
- Well, I've been planning
this for a couple weeks
and I should backup and clarify and say,
it's nutrition based and so,
it's very hands-on with choosing
the right foods based on
what's on the time.
- That makes sense.
That makes sense.
My problem is, you're trying
to build top of funnel
to convert when you go in for the ask.
- Okay.
- And if I said to you, "Can
you launch it in six weeks?"
You might not be able
to afford it, I get it.
You might have over promised
on the launch right now,
and you can't go back.
I get it, I get it.
But, in general,
especially because we have
tens of thousands of people watching
and I want them to win.
If you're ever gonna go down this model,
I'm hoping for as much time as possible
because that allows you
to, and Jill's got it,
to jab more than right hook,
because when you've got
a short period of time,
two weeks is...
You're immediately going
into conversion mode.
It's like going to the
club on Saturday night
and looking to hook up.
You're not romancing at the office
and building that relationship.
You're trying to go in for the kill,
that's where all the scum
bucket dudes come out, right?
And I don't want businesses
to be that version,
so I'm always trying to stretch that out.
I'm also trying to create a framework
where you don't feel like
it's a forever one year thing,
where in 90 days, you can do another class
and run in parallel,
because I want you to
romance, not try to close.
- And the beauty about this is that,
because it's over a three month span,
I get to go ahead and work closely,
and I definitely don't
expect huge numbers,
I have about 20 people
that have signed up,
so I'm excited.
- That's awesome.
- Yeah.
- That's a great start.
- I'm totally excited, I'm wondering how--
- Do you have a URL?
Maybe you can get a couple more here,
you have a URL?
- Yes, it's nourishmasters.com
- Good look with that, Dustin,
I can't spell for shit.
(laughing)
- Okay.
- And the other thing is,
I'm trying to reach 40 plus
because I know that--
- Well, listen, Facebook and
Instagram is at this point too.
Look, if you've got dollars,
or when you get dollars,
Facebook and Instagram ads,
you've heard this at nausea from me,
they fucking work.
It just matters what the content is.
If you go on you're like,
"Hey you can lose 40..."
You know, if it's fucking
infomercials, it's garbage.
If it's a fucking HBO
documentary, quality content,
it crushes.
- I'm so excited about
this, I really am because--
- Have you texted ever single person
in your contact phone book?
- I have--
- And said,
"Hey, I'm doing this,
if you or anybody that
you know is interested."
Have you gone there?
Or are you too worried to be
tone deaf during this time?
What's your vibe on that?
- I've started to.
I've started to reach out to everyone.
And I've tried to let it be known
that this is what I'm doing now,
and I've heard some people say,
"Wow, this sounds exciting,
I just can't do it now."
I've had some people say...
I've had a couple people
sign up in that matter.
- Okay.
- Which, and I totally appreciate.
I felt like the vibe has been like,
"Wow, this is something
that I'm looking for.
I don't necessarily want
a meal plan thrown at me
which is why I wanted to have
the webinar to meal prep.
- I love it, I love it.
- To have and in addition to that,
I am having some workouts,
two to three a week.
- I love it.
- Where it's gonna be
from a progressive move.
- I love it.
- So that that will--
- I like where you're going.
- I appre--
- Good luck to you.
I love your energy too.
- Thank you, I appreciate that.
- Facebook ads will work.
- Okay.
- Spend five hours during this quarantine,
at night or in the morning,
because obviously, you
have your hands full,
and learn it.
- Okay.
- It's no different than
what you tell people
in learning nutrition and health.
- Yep.
- People are really good
at giving advice to learn something,
and be disciplined in the thing they know,
and then they're not good at learning
and being disciplined
in the thing that doesn't come natural,
and they don't know.
That's why getting into shape
is the single thing I'm most proud of,
because it was the hardest for me
because it didn't come natural.
I spent all my time at
what does come natural,
and what I love which is why I'm so happy,
but getting into shape was not.
And once I was able to overcome that,
in the last five or six years,
it's given me confidence
to not be a hypocrite
when I give advice to you,
of spend seven hours and
watch videos and read
to be great at making Facebook ads.
- Exactly, I appreciate
everything that you're saying.
I feel like I'm in sponge mode
trying to learn and step
out of my comfort zone
and be okay with it, knowing
this is uncomfortable,
but I'm willing to grow.
- Good.
- And if I fall on my face,
- I'll still get back up.
- Take care of yourself.
- All right, thank you, Gary.
- My (mumbles) thank you,
you were great.
- Thank you.
- You're absolutely great.
K.J. Delver, what's good?
Michael, good.
Kim Jacobs, "You're beautiful,"
I know she was saying that
to the other person but...
Yes, winetext.com is here.
Robin's in the building.
All right, let's move it.
- Hello, Gary, how's it going, man?
- It's going really well @teawithmike,
how are you?
- I'm good, we've finally met,
Tea with Gary Vee and @teawithmike.
I'm really pumped to be
given this opportunity
to be on.
- Pleasure.
How are you?
- Really good, thanks.
I'll start buy asking you,
what's you're favorite type of tea?
- I'm a very big oolong,
silver needle oolong,
is my favorite tea, Mike.
- Very nice, so my favorite type of tea
is a Yorkshire tea,
it's a nice strong black tea.
I'm originally from England.
I'm now living in Canada,
and I just love tea, man.
- Me too.
Now, obviously, you know,
I'm from Russian decent,
and you said England,
so both of us have the fortune
of coming from very heavy tea cultures.
- Absolutely.
- Was that parents or grandparents
that got you into it early?
- Yeah, absolutely, like you mentioned,
it's a cultural thing,
been drinking it since
I was a young child,
started off with tea in a bottle
with lots of milk in,
and then gradually as I got older,
I've developed into drinking strong tea
with just a tiny bit of milk.
- Yes.
Of course, yeah, right.
Because the milk, obviously,
it's so cultural for you,
but then getting really to the nuances
of the tannins and the flavors,
the milk is disguising it.
- Absolutely.
So, next stage, I've been
following you for over two years.
- Thank you.
- Obviously, thank you
for helping to teach me
consistency, gratitude,
and engaging with others,
and most importantly of
all, just being yourself
because that's really all that you can do
at the end of the day.
- 100% my friend, 100%.
- Yeah.
- Is there a question you have?
- Absolutely.
- Yes.
- You might know that I
have the Tea with Mike show,
it's a story telling show,
it's all about human
interaction, communication.
It's been going over a year now,
it's been going really well.
- That's awesome.
- I have nearly 2,000
followers on Facebook
and I've just recorded my
50th episode the other day.
- Good for you.
- My question is, do you
have any promotion tips?
- Yeah.
- Anything I should be looking at
to continue the long term growth
of what I'm building from the ground up?
- I would reach out to other YouTubers,
and content makers, and
do collaboration shows.
When I started Wine Library TV in 2006,
I was such an early
pioneer in that format,
and doing things with
Ze Frank or Rocketboom,
or individuals, Kevin
Rose from Dig, Tim Ferris,
those things really mattered.
I think you need to crosspollinate.
Your format is very easy
to crosspollinate with.
You could basically go to any show,
and bring tea and interact with.
I would do a lot of outreach and say,
"Hey, would you like
to do a collaboration?"
Inevitably, there's other beverage,
there's unlimited beer and coffee shows
that you could do a collab with,
I think Zoom and Google Hangout,
videos like this right now, virtually.
It's just about asking.
Back to you saying, "being yourself,"
that really hit me when you delivered it.
It hit different than the other things.
It all comes down to self-esteem.
Having the self-esteem
to reach out to people
and being okay when they say no
has been my greatest strength.
So many people crumble when
people don't reply to them
or when they say no,
that it doesn't allow them
to actually move forward.
They feel like if they
don't get replied to...
Like, I hit up people and I
see that they've see the DM,
and they don't reply to me.
And I'm thrilled, I have
no ego towards that,
I don't get hurt by that.
I think you need to go that route.
- Also, is it--
- Collaborations on
content that you watch.
- Collaborations.
Sweet, and I think that's
what I've really learnt
as I mentioned, and so far,
and just really being that patient
and enjoying each step of the way.
Obviously, in the past couple of
my Tweets I sent through,
and the moment when I learnt
that I was gonna be on the show,
it was kind of like a pinned dropped,
because I've been working
towards that goal,
engaging with different people
through #teawithgaryvee on Twitter,
and obviously engaging with your team
because they're all really great people.
- Thank you.
- And awesome human beings.
Shout out to them.
- Thank you.
- And then, the moment
when it actually happened,
I just stopped, it was like...
(laughing)
I've achieved this little step
and it really made me think,
"What can I achieve next?"
- You know, it's funny, it's why I do it.
I saw you trying to get
attention of it and I watch.
And sometimes people...
There's people on Twitter
or in here right now
or texting or DMing you
tried to get my attention for three years,
and some of this is intuition,
some of it's luck.
There was some person here that was saying
I was on for the first time,
I literally called out their name,
there's been people that
have been here every second.
There's so much chance in life.
The key is not to dwell
on when your unlucky,
and get upset when somebody...
And envy when somebody's lucky.
The key is to understand
that there's so much serendipity in life.
And don't dwell and say
it's because of you,
understand that it's just
bigger than all of us
and just keep moving forward
and recognizing even,
I'm a big fan of, people are like,
"Don't worry, your time will come."
I don't think that's true.
I'm not so sure if your time will come.
I think you need to love the process
of trying to have your time to come.
- Awesome, thank you,
and so, my right hook is,
(laughing)
you're coming to Edmonton in September?
- Yes, yes.
- I'm really excited
for that, as you know,
because I've been Tweeting
about it quite a bit,
so my right hook is, can I meet you
when you come to Ed--
- Yes.
Yes, you can.
- Appreciate it man.
- I'll take you backstage.
Dustin will get you to Zane
or Zane will get us up.
I'll get you to the green room
right before we go on stage
and rip everybody's faces off
with my energy and insights.
- Dude, I love it, thank you so much.
- You're welcome, Mike.
- And thanks for everything you do.
- Happy to do it.
- I'm @teawithmike,
teawithmike.com is my website.
- Love it.
- I just updated it last night
so it's fresh with people's stories.
- You must have been last night,
"Okay, I'm going on with Gary tomorrow,
I got to get my shit tight."
- Don't worry man.
- I love it.
- I saw you tweet in those--
- It's like a fresh cut
before you go on a date.
I like it Mike, I like how you went.
- Okay.
- All right, bro, talk to you.
- Thanks again.
See you in September.
- Bye-bye, can't wait to see you.
Hi everybody, I'm really
enjoying today's show.
Let's get one more in
before we're out of here.
And then I got a big ask
for the All In Challenge.
Hey, Laci.
Is that how you pronounce it?
- Yes.
- Awesome, how are you?
- Good, how are you?
Thank you and your team for letting me on.
I feel like a pressure.
- Happy to have you on.
Where you from?
- I'm from Chandler, Arizona.
- Fantastic.
- Okay so, I'll start.
I'm a young healthcare professional.
I'm in the field of Audiology,
so I identify and treat
managed hearing loss.
But, my question is,
if you're a young healthcare
professional right now,
whether you're a dentist or
a young speech pathologist
or speech, optometrist,
or whatever you are,
you're passionate about.
How do you make your mark in the industry
and make an impression in your field
when you're so young.
And so, you're a healthcare professional,
you're not a marketer,
you're not entrepreneur.
I've been watching your content.
I'm still relatively new to your content
for about two months now.
- Thank you.
- And you're a strong preacher on
"Don't fake it 'till you make it,"
and "Document your journey
to becoming the expert."
But I'm having a hard
time taking that advice
and applying it to the healthcare field,
when the expectation already is that
you should know your stuff as an expert,
that's why your patients come to you.
You already have that
credibility already built in.
That's why you graduated medical school,
graduate school, dentistry school.
- There's a difference between
Lebron James his rookie year,
and the Lebron James today.
You don't have to say you don't know,
you have to say you do know,
that's how you got certified
and that's how you're here,
but you can document thoughts, hypotheses,
insights, challenges to the system.
The other thing you can do
is interview the people that
are where you want to be.
The other format you can go
is instead of being me
who puts out direct and builds community
and is just a very below
average interviewer
because he intuitively knows
what the person's about to say
and then tends to cut the
of and "duh, duh, duh."
You might be a great interviewer
like the legendary Barbara Walters,
one of the people I most admire, ever,
in the public eye.
So what you might be able to do
is now reach out to people
who've been in the space for 35 years.
Right now they're sitting
at home, a lot of them,
and are thrilled to be
asked to be on a podcast
for an interview video or Zoom
that you put out on LinkedIn,
and what you may do is instead of
documenting how you're getting
educated along the way,
maybe you actually flip it,
and you interview people in
all certain different sectors,
and through the interview questions,
there's almost this
siphoning of credibility
that's happening between
the conversations,
including when you have your own...
What's amazing about
being young professions
is you have new ideas, right?
- Yes.
- So, when your interviewing
one of the top 15 in your field,
'cause she just happened to say yes
when you asked her on LinkedIn
because she's thrilled
to just do something different right now,
the greatest time to get
guests on things is right now.
Right?
When you ask her, "Hey, Susan,
one thing I've been thinking a lot about
as I'm entering the field
through my studies and first
couple years of my career is,
I don't get why people do
this thing with the lobe.
Or, why do people at home..."
And then, where it gets interesting is,
if you have a real compelling thought,
in that moment where she
has to answer and say,
"Ah, that's more of a systems issue,
I agree with you."
That's how I built my
credibility in the wine world.
I was not faking it.
I was just challenging the status quo
from my own experience and my perspective.
Which led to interesting dialogue,
which many things ended up educating me
on why they were that way,
and other things became that
I became historically correct
with my insights that nobody
had challenged in the past
from the angle and the perception
that I was coming from.
- Okay, okay.
Yeah, LinkedIn is definitely
where all the professionals
go to right now,
because were so young,
it's kind of intimidating,
but I will definitely
look into that right now.
- I think you have a really
incredible opportunity
to reach out to 500 leading
professionals and say,
"Hey, I'm starting to interview people
just to create some valuable
content on LinkedIn,
it will give you some exposure."
And away you'll go.
I think you can really
build some relationships.
- Okay, the other question is too,
the one question I have.
Hold on one second, Laci.
- Okay.
- Go back.
Dustin, put that last comment up.
Dustin, can you join us,
can we do a three way here?
(laughing)
Yeah, Dustin, I'm not
sure if you understand
the format of this show.
But it's not necessarily
to pat yourself on the back
by putting up...
I don't know where you're going with this,
I don't know if you did this for your mom
or what are we doing here?
- Sometimes I just click to like...
And it's moving while I'm clicking.
- Dustin, are you claiming...
Because I know you have a
tremendous sense of humor.
Are you claiming that this
was pinned by accident?
- Yes.
- Or were you having
a little bit of fun?
- No, it's accident.
I'm trying to find the next best one
and they're going so fast so I'm like...
- Yeah, all right.
- I have reading problems. (laughs)
- All right.
- He's amazing, he's amazing.
- I know he's amazing,
All right, Dustin, get out of here.
- I'll be honest, if I tried--
- Somebody's typing, Dustin, by the way.
Go ahead.
- In the two episodes
that I've seen you on,
both times Dustin made me laugh
because I never knew who he is
but he should...
- Yeah, my number one goal
with Tea with Gary Vee
is to make Dustin a superstar.
- Okay, there you go.
- We did it for D-Rock.
We did it for Chris Mott,
we did it for India.
I wish people analyzed what I do more.
I believe that giving
is the single most important
thing in the world.
Of course.
- I really--
- Of course we should
care about ourselves.
I care about myself and
my family quite a bit.
But giving comes in a lot of forms.
Quietly behind the scenes
- Yeah.
- to donations, publicly
like the All In Challenge,
doing nice things.
- Yes, yes.
- And building up Dustin.
- Yes, there you go,
and then here's the thing too,
right now the field that I'm in,
it's just not awareness right now.
I want to tap in and to get
the people's attentions first
so that I can eventually
spread that level of awareness.
- Interview people, listen to me.
Interview people.
Try it.
Try it for two weeks.
Email thoughtfully 500 people and say,
"I want to interview on Zoom,
and put on LinkedIn to help people."
Tell me what happens.
- Okay.
- We'll have you back in two weeks.
500 people.
- 500?
- 500.
- Okay.
- Yeah, not 50.
- You can do it.
- No, I know, I know.
- Last night I was up 'till...
I was 3:00am last night,
I'm trying to get Jim Carry to donate art
for the All In Challenge.
When your invigorated, you can do it.
You can do it.
- Okay, okay.
Well, what about TikTok?
- TikTok's amazing, and
you should do it anyway.
- Should professionals be on it.
Should health care professionals?
- Yes, yes, yes.
- Okay.
- As a human.
- 100%.
- My real light is coming.
- I can't wait.
Thank you for being on.
Bye-bye.
- Thank you so much.
- Take care.
All right, Dustin,
thank you for being on
the one's and two's today.
(laughs) Even that one made
me laugh a quick second.
(laughing)
Put up the All In Challenge
at theallinchallenge.com.
This is very important to me.
I'm gonna close with this.
I have to go to my next meeting.
Let me see what my next meeting is.
Can I get a second or am I fucked?
All right I got to go.
But...
Can't go, okay.
All In Challenge.
If you're watching right
now and you can afford it,
and many cannot, so this is not for you.
And obviously this is American execution
because the way sweepstakes
and auction laws work,
and where the charities that
we're sending the money to.
It would just mean the world to me.
I don't know if you guys know...
Dustin, for tomorrow's Tea with Gary Vee,
can you play my whole video
of what I'm giving away at the end?
- Mm-hmm.
- 'Cause when I go in for this ask.
Because I don't think people understand
how crazy it is.
- Yeah.
- $25,000 shopping spree at Wine Library,
go to a Jets game,
go garage selling with me,
be on my podcast,
fly you to three keynotes,
real stuff.
Wine dinner, week at VaynerMedia,
with Tea with Gary Vee,
you can fucking take a selfie with Dustin.
(laughing)
Anyway, you're out of here Dustin.
All right, I need you guys All In.
Please buy some tickets in to me,
please if you're a high
net worth individual,
look at some of the
auctions, it's incredible.
Some of the stuff is incredible.
It would mean the world to me
if you supported the All In Challenge.
Please go there right now
and buy some raffle tickets.
They're 10 bucks a piece.
You can buy 200 of them for $100
and the five bucks a piece.
One of you can literally for five dollars
win a year with me.
Go watch the video on the site.
All In Challenge.
And if you can't, minimum every person,
please put on Twitter and on Facebook,
Allinchallenge.com, build awareness.
Thank you so much, (kissing) I love you.
See you later.
Take care, love you, see you, bye.
- Okay so, Team Gary has made
a lot of content over the years,
but what's your favorite piece
of content that was made?
- That's a great question.
My favorite content by far
is, I'm considering doing
a VaynerMedia Operations
stay at home day once a week, forever,
because I'm pretty sold that
I've gotten more done per day
than sometimes in a month.
(whooshing)